you can see the same table they
are shooting at david look here at the
block below look where alberto
rodríguez is everyone left the
discotheque - alberto rodríguez stayed in
the same place observing that
the plan has been executed looking to keep it in
the box  from below, everyone
left, you saw that if he still
helps David get up when he is injured,
however, the discotheque or the bar is cleaned
and the only one who remains is the man who
is at the bar from 5:40 a.m. and
after  everything
then is when he leaves it
is another angle of when the
event occurs the shot is fired and everyone
disappears but he keeps
observing that the operation was yielded he
takes his beer and puts it back but he
stays there alone
in full observation verifying
everything  what is there is surprised by the
shot but there is a person who does
not flinch who simply observes
what was executed